zwingen uns äußere umstände dem nächster
zu unseren heimatplaneten zu verlassen
immer wieder gibt es warnungen dass der
klimawandel die erde schon bald
unbewohnbar machen könnte fest steht
jedenfalls spätestens in fünf milliarden
jahren wird die sonne das gesamte leben
auf der erde auslöschen und so tüfteln
forschungsteams weltweit an ideen den
menschen eine neue heimat zu schaffen
statt den mars zu besiedeln könnte man
aber auch dem gesamten planeten erde
einen neuen platz im universum
organisieren doch wie genau könnten wir
die erde verschieben und so das
überleben der menschheit sichern
ein schottischer raumfahrtexperte hat
dazu eine vision entwickelt klicks um
science-fiction lebens täglich spannende
science - abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen jetzt haben wir fast schon
die halbzeit erreicht denn die
entstehung der sonne liegt 4,6
milliarden jahre zurück und noch rund 6
milliarden jahre lang wird sie wohl wie
ein normaler stern brennen und 40
prozent heller ist die sonne nun schon
seit ihrer entstehung geworden und klar
ist umso heller sie wird desto wärmer
wird auch die erde schätzung zufolge
wird die erde in 1,1 milliarden jahren
so warm sein dass auf ihren nur noch
wüsten bestehen können denn zu dieser
zeit wird die sonne noch einmal 10
prozent heller sein als es derzeit der
fall ist der wasserstoff im kern der
sonne wird immer weiter aufgebraucht und
sorgt so dafür dass in etwa 3,5
milliarden jahren sogar die meere auf
der erde verdampfen werden in 6,3
milliarden jahren wird der wasserstoff
dann komplett aufgebraucht sein und die
fusion kommt zum erliegen
der überdruck im kern singt die hülle
wird durch die gravitation nach innen
gezogen der wasserstoff der noch in der
hülle vorhanden ist erhitzt sich so dass
auch hier eine kernfusion zündet es
werden unvorstellbare mengen an energie
frei die auch die äußeren schichten
erhitzen die sonnen dehnt sich aus
innerhalb der darauf folgende 1,3
milliarden jahre wird sie auf das 100
bis 150 fache ihrer jetzigen größe
anwachsen höchstwahrscheinlich wird die
sonne dabei auch die erde verschlingen
doch nicht nur dieses szenario lässt
forschungsteams weltweiten überlegungen
anstellen wie sich das überleben der
menschheit sichern lässt auch die
globale klimakrise könnte dafür sorgen
dass unser heimat kann
nicht mehr bewohnbar ist der
raumfahrtexperte matteo zotti von der
university glasgow hat jetzt einen frei
verfügbaren aufsatz im netz
veröffentlicht in dem er überlegungen
anstellt wie die erde
vielleicht doch noch zu retten ist
demnach könnten wir einer drohenden
apokalypse entgehen indem wir die erde
in eine andere umlaufbahn bringen würden
diese müsste 50 prozent weiter von der
sonne entfernt sein als dieses maß das
hätte den großen vorteil dass wir
unseren heimatplaneten gar nicht
verlassen müssten anders als es
beispielsweise bei einer maß besiedlung
der fall wäre laut matteo charity wäre
diese idee technisch gesehen sogar
umsetzbar der experte bringt dafür
elektrische triebwerke ins gespräch er
vergleicht dies mit dem start einer
rakete die die erde verlässt durch die
triebkraft wird die erde jedes mal
minimal in die entgegengesetzte richtung
verschoben vergleichbar mit dem rückstoß
einer waffe doch charity sagt auch dass
mehrere milliardenpaketen für diesen
plan gleichzeitig abgeben müssen erst
durch den start von 300 milliarden
falcon heavy von spacex könnte die erde
tatsächlich signifikant verschoben
werden der planet würde so die
umlaufbahn des mars erreichen eine
andere idee wäre ist eine art triebwerk
an die erdatmosphäre zu installieren
eine ionenantrieb also an strom
geladener partikel würde die erde
langsam aber sicher in einen anderen
orbit bringen dieses mega triebwerk
müsste charity zufolge etwa 1000
kilometer über dem meeresspiegel
angebracht werden und fest mit der erde
verbunden werden um die schubkraft zu
übertragen doch auch hier gibt es
schwierigkeiten dem um 87% der erde zu
bewegen müssten wir das äquivalent von
13% der erdmasse in ionen form ausstoßen
wie sollte das in der praxis
funktionieren in seinem aufsatz schreibt
serie über einen weiteren ansatz die
erde innerhalb des sonnensystems zu
bewegen und zwar durch eine art laser
die energie für diesen fokussierten
nicht strahlt könnten wir von der sonne
selbst bekommen doch das würde viel zu
lange dauern drei milliarden jahre
ununterbrochener nutzung wäre
den berechnungen zufolge nötig um eine
änderung der umlaufbahn zu erreichen das
wäre dann wohl etwas zu spät aber könnte
vielleicht ein gigantisches solarsegel
abhilfe schaffen jerry und im bezieht
sich hier auf eine studie
dem jahr 2002 nachdem solch ein
sonnensegel neben der erde einen 19 mal
größeren durchmesser haben müsste als
die erde selbst ein umzug durch das
sonnensystem würde dann eine milliarde
jahre dauern
als eine weitere möglichkeit die erde zu
verschieben beschreibt der experte den
vorgang der gravitation schleuder schon
seit den dollar raum sondern wird diese
technik der sogenannten zwingend bei
manöver genutzt damit raum sollten quasi
kostenlos energie tanken können die
gravitationskraft der planeten wird hier
genutzt um raumsonden zu beschleunigen
oder auch abzubremsen denn wenn die
sonde als leichter körpernah an einem
vergleichsweise schweren himmelskörper
vorbeifliegt bekommt sie quasi energie
von ihm so kann nicht nur die
geschwindigkeit sondern auch die
flugrichtung geändert werden um die erde
selbst zu bewegen bräuchte ist laut
chariot etwas deutlich größeres als eine
raumsonde kometen oder asteroiden
könnten verwendet werden auch wenn
dieser vorgang dann mehrmals wiederholt
werden müsste um die erde in einen
anderen ort zu schieben
fingerspitzengefühl wäre gefragt wenn
ein kleiner körper aus seiner umlaufbahn
geschleudert werden muss um an der erde
vorbei schwingen und ihr so einen großen
impuls verleiht schätzungen zur folge
wäre eine million solcher vorbeiflüge an
hast du ihnen notwendig um die erde von
der sonne wegzubewegen auch dazu hatte
es bereits 2001 eine studie gegeben
tatsächlich kommt zu dem fazit dass der
einsatz von mehreren astori schleudern
am realistischen sei die erde an einen
sicheren ort zu verschieben solch einen
technik- und auch der einsatz eines
solarsegel sein in der zukunft noch am
ehesten in der praxis umzusetzen der
wissenschaftler hofft zudem darauf das
licht in der nahen zukunft weitere
möglichkeiten für einen möglichen umzug
der erde bieten könnte die entwicklung
super starker laser airways
beispielsweise könnte der knackpunkt
sein um die erde mit hilfe von licht zu
verschieben und den planeten und das
gesamte leben auf ihn vor der zerstörung
durch die sonne zu retten klimawandel
bedroht küstengebiete kampf oder rückt
ja dann beginnt jetzt schon die
umsiedlung noch auf unserem planeten
anklicken anschauen und krieg zum nature
abonnieren wenn ihr euch für radtouren
umwelt interessiert ist das ein pflicht
abo also bis dann drauf klicken und
bleibt dran